6 43 on your Thursday morning how about  some Hometown hockey the golden knights  with a 7 P.M puck drop tonight they're  hosting the Detroit Red Wings at  T-Mobile on Saturday the knights welcome  the year of the rabbit when they host  the Washington Capitals now on Saturday  night they're going to wear warm-up  jerseys that do say golden knights just  in the Mandarin language those jerseys  will be signed by the players and  auctioned you can still get some tickets  for both tonight's game as well as  Saturday night's game by the way for  Saturday there's a bonus for fans you  get a free Lunar New Year themed vgk  scarf how about that John and Heather  sweaters look really good that's awesome  well and you're the rabbit is lucky so  maybe it'll bring the golden knights a  little bit of luck but you can only hope